[Música]
es para mí otro desafío bastante grande
porque es un clásico muy importante que
vuelve cada año y porque es muy familiar
especialmente para los niños y porque yo
creo que me trae muchas memorias de
cuando era pequeña y me gusta poder
ayudar
mantener esa ilusión cuando uno está tan
pequeño y todo es mágico y todo es como
sorprendente pues como que me me hace
mucha ilusión de poder compartir esos
sueños o de mantener esa ilusión viva en
los niños y también es es difícil porque
a veces que venimos de hacer un
un programa muy diferente contemporáneo
con otras características muy diferentes
y entonces meterse en el cascanueces
la apariencia técnica física y los
caracteres que en escenarios son
bastante diferentes y también tenemos
poco tiempo para preparar los
espectáculos pues porque estamos muy
ocupados con otros espectáculos también
es es una ilusión y al mismo tiempo es
otro desafío grande también son
bastantes representaciones en todo el
mes como 20 y tantas y también el
cansancio al final pues
le llega a uno en las piernas sobre todo
pero al mismo tiempo en el corazón
porque nos ayuda a los bailarines a
mantenernos en ese espíritu festivo y de
familia un poco con
la infancia
[Música]